[Musique]
maintenant est ce que l'économie sera au
coeur de la prochaine campagne
électorale notre ca du vendredi avec
béatrice alain directrice générale du
chantier de l'économie sociale et
marcelin joanis professeur titulaire au
département de mathématiques et de génie
industriel gelé 1,2 polytechnique
montréal
bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir bonsoir
alors quatre ans plus tard béatrice
d'abord dans quel état et l'économie du
québec pour vous mais je pense que
il ya des indicateurs puis le
gouvernement parlait qui sont moins pire
que ce qu'on pourrait penser et étant
donné la crise les inquiétudes que sa
cause est mais je pense qu'il a tout
dépend des indicateurs qu'on regarde on
compare contre quoi contre les autres
contre le passé où est ce qu'on regarde
pour moi au delà des emplois puis du du
salaire à ce qu'on regarde
l'accessibilité de services pertinents
le durabilité l'impact environnementaux
de nos choix économiques
donc je pense qu'il ya des grandes
questions encore sur le modèle
économique grand qu'on promeut questions
structurelles sur l'économie dites vous
marcelin joanis qu'est ce que vous en
pensez dans quel état et l'économie du
québec pour vous je pense que si on
regarde d'un point de vue conjoncturel
je pense qu'il faut l'admettre
l'économie
l'économie a été résiliente l'économie
du québec je pense y ont reculé en 2020
l'a jamais on aurait cru aujourd'hui
regardez les jambes le genre de chiffre
qu'on voit aujourd'hui sur la croissance
économique sur le chômage etc donc oui
la photo aujourd'hui avant l'été là elle
est positive maintenant il ya des nuages
noirs qui s'amoncellent à l'horizon il
ya des risques d'orage pour l'économie
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
mentionné l'inflation les taux d'intérêt
et les risques qui sont liées qui sont
liées à sa donc où est ce qu'on lancera
à l'automne ça c'est une autre paire de
manche là et l'inflation les taux
d'intérêts ça nous appartient pas
tellement quand même deux parce qu'il se
passe des choses dans le monde entier
qui ont un impact par exemple sur
l'offre sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
monsieur legault dit qu'à score et fort
leur sur différents éléments économiques
mais par exemple la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre où la dévitalisation des
régions béatrice année où la crise du
logement ce sont des facteurs sur
lesquels le gouvernement peut agir
effectivement s'il ya une partie qu'on
peut pas contrôler il ya des politiques
publiques puis un développement
économique qui réduit l'impact de cette
inflation donc sortir développer du
logement qui sort d'une logique de
spéculation notamment parce qu'elle est
contrôlée par la communauté avant des
circuits plus courts en agroalimentaire
et être moins affectées par des chocs
d'impact économique puis avoir en
général une économie plus réseauter chez
nous est plus ancrée localement nous
mais moins aux dépens de grandes
multinationales qui elles vivent
beaucoup le contrecoup des chaînes
d'approvisionnement des hausses de coûts
etc c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que on l'a beaucoup entendu
pendant la pandémie c'est pas tant un
repli protectionniste comme quoi il faut
davantage développer nos circuits à
l'intérieur pour être moins dépendant de
l'extérieur
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre également
marcelin joanis le québec peut agir est
ce qu il agi suffisamment là dessus oui
mais bon c'est quand on quand on arrive
en période électorale c'est tentant de
faire des liens de cause à effet entre
l'état de l'économie et les politiques
gouvernementales
je veux pas minimiser le rôle que joue
les gouvernements mais vous l'avez
mentionné il ya quelques instants en
fait il y avait il ya des grandes
tendances au tant internes qu'externes
contre lesquelles on se bat et il faut
il faut faire attention pour le
gouvernement de ne pas trop s'attribuer
les succès et de ne pas trop espérer non
plus qu'on est capable ce qu'on est
capable de faire
à court terme vous le mentionnez aussi
tout à l'heure c'est important de le
mentionner l'inflation les taux
d'intérêt bas c'est pas de juridiction
provinciale cette juridiction fédérale
ceci dit les élections qu'on aura cet
automne best une rencontre entre le
gouvernement et une occasion pour les
électeurs de de rencontrer les décideurs
politiques et moi je pense que ces
enjeux là même si le gouvernement a peu
de contrôle de le gouvernement du québec
un peu de contrôle dessus bah c'est de
ça que nos politiciens provinciaux vont
entendre parler
l'inflation est l'enjeu économique
incontournable de la campagne marcelin
joanis moi je suis convaincu que c'est
de ça que la population va va parler aux
policiers cet été c'est certain les
chiffres quand on les regarde je voyais
installer les commentaires que vous
receviez d'auditeurs c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que je pense qu'une
bonne éducation que au delà des chiffres
qui peuvent sembler un peu lointain les
gens commencent à s'inquiéter très
sérieusement la situation sur le terrain
les taux d'intérêt qu'elle va être
l'impact pour moi l'inflation quel va
être l'impact est est ce que mon revenu
va suivre aussi aussi très bien mais
j'ai juste revenir sur la question de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre je pense qu'il
faut situer qu'on a des enjeux sociaux
au québec qui deviennent des enjeux
économiques quand les soins aux
personnes vulnérables sont pas adéquats
et que les femmes quittent le marché du
travail ou réduisent leur présence dans
l'économie c'est un impact économique
quand on cherche des emplois dans les
régions mais on n'a pas où les loger ou
des services de proximité pertinent pour
attirer et maintenir les familles les
travailleurs
c'est un enjeu économique également qui
nuit à notre capacité de croissance puis
le dernier enjeu c'est pour moi la
question environnementale je suis
entièrement d'accord qu'on va parler
d'inflation mais l'éléphant dans la
pièce c'est qu'on a un modèle économique
qui est pas durable et qu'on voit
constamment entraîne des enjeux
économiques et sociaux j'étais aux îles
de la madeleine ce matin on parle
d'érosion en dessous du x est magnifique
mais les cas passez les enjeux de
logements convoi pour notamment attirer
les travailleurs puis l'érosion en
dessous d'infrastructures comme les clsc
du jeudi il ya un enjeu à long terme qui
est incontournable qu'on ne auquel on ne
s'attaque pas suffisamment à mon
environnement est clairement un enjeu
économique est ce que est ce qu'on va
parler d'environnement marcenais
joanisse durant la campagne électorale
vous pensez suis tout à fait d'accord
qu'on devrait en parler que ça devrait
être l'enjeu prioritaire à chaque
élection aux pose la question est-ce que
c'est l'élection où on va enfin parler
d'environnement
j'espère que oui ceci dit pour qui c'est
un défi un pour les partis politiques je
leur lance un défi pour qu'on parle d'un
enjeu pendant une campagne électorale
j'ai acquis la conviction là qu'il faut
que les parties expriment extrêmement
clairement quelles sont leurs positions
et il faut que les positions diffèrent
en fait il faut qu'il y ait un débat il
faut il faut qu'il ya un enjeu au niveau
de l'élection est souvent finalement
autant économique en environnement où il
ya des différences elles sont subtiles
puis nous on s'amuse à l'est entre nous
à les disséquer mais pour la population
en général c'est difficile de percevoir
ces différents cela est très souvent
l'environnement en particulier mais
aussi les enjeux de politique économique
tom un petit peu la passe un peu aux
oubliettes parce qu'il ya des enjeux qui
sont peut-être plus divisif qui prennent
le dessus en même temps vous vous parler
d'inflation je présume qu'on va beaucoup
parler d'inflation parce que c'est une
préoccupation dans la vie des gens c'est
une préoccupation économique monsieur
legault a fait son lit très clairement
il veut parler d'immigration veux parler
de fierté il veut parler de l'identité
du québec l'immigration est-elle
béatrice alain une solution à la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre et ce sujet doit-il
être débattu durant la campagne
électorale je pense que il ya une
pression pour embaucher plus de gens
mais encore une fois pour moi il ya des
conditions pour que l'ensemble des
québécois qui veulent travailler
puissent le faire et notamment notre
signer sociale mais aussi les conditions
dans toutes les régions donc pour moi le
débat il est pas juste calculez le
nombre de postes qui sont à pourvoir et
faire rentrer les gens mais voir dans
quelles conditions les accueille dans
quel genre d'emploi puis commence à
contribuer ultime en accroître le
bien-être des québécois c'est à dire une
qualité de vie avec des services de
proximité pertinent une certaine
cohésion sociale exceptionnelle joanisse
là dessus ouais ben pour moi
l'immigration ça fait certainement
partie du cocktail de mesures dont on a
besoin pour s'attaquer à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui est un enjeu de court
terme mais aussi de long terme mais je
mentionnerai aussi des enjeux liés à
l'éducation de façon plus générale
un enjeu là parmi les défis la prochaine
de la prochaine décennie a certainement
faire un suivi très étroits de ce qu'ont
vécu nos jeunes pendant là pendant la
pandémie et s'assurer que nos jeunes
gens et un avenir brillant devant eux
puis qu'on se soucie aussi des enjeux
comme le décrochage scolaire par exemple
et donc l'immigration oui et et toute
une série d'autres mesures s'en fait
partie ça vous êtes vraiment intéressant
j'ai beaucoup aimé tout ce que vous avez
dit sans prendre partie bien sûr merci
marcelin joanis merci béatrice alex
était très intéressant merci nous aura
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]